and somehow snatched stal mayate from
the jaws of defeat that's the confidence
you need and we've said from the
beginning for those of you who were with
us we previewed the bleep out of this
thing and one theme remains consistent
throughout Wesley so's career when he's
confident he does things like win the
Fisher random world championship and he
does things like win the chess.com
Global Championship when he's not
confident da he does things like lose 11
games in a row to Magnus on chess.com
and and so that's a huge moment that he
didn't lose those first two games to
start today's match and Dan you took the
words right out of right out of my mouth
we really complete each other as um as
as sandwiches or send I'm into whatever
you want to complete I'm here all night
sandwi I would love a sandwich right now
but Wesley you know yeah he didn't win
that game and you know he did get that
lost position out of an end game that
where he seemed to be playing for two
results although you're never playing
for two results against Magnus you can
lose any end game to him but this does
grant you a lot of confidence and Wesley
wait a second I actually save some of
these end games I can compete with
Magnus in the end game and that was a
big practical boost as we see an old
school line of the knorf this used to be
popular in the 80s and 90s uh this
opposite weird opposite color Bishop
middle game with three pawns on the
defile
yep yeah this is uh funny stuff because
opposite code Bishop endgames superr
opposite code Bishop middle games if
white gets going on the on the light
squares this becomes a very very
dangerous position for black to hold and
uh they have a lot of time on the clock
here which tells me both of these
players at least at least know something
about this one even if they haven't
looked at this theory in a while yeah
this bishop G5 Bishop takes F6 line uh I
think Vladimir kramnick pioneered uh
some of them the ideas in in the early
90s and it's always kind of stuck around
as as a good backup system to the more
topical responses to the KN or like
Bishop G5 and now of course the English
attack and and 6 H3 I think the position
is dynamically equal uh black has good
chances to generate pressure on the
queen side the queen from d8 it can come
out to A5 The Rook from A8 can come out
to E8 grabbing control of the E file and
I'm just not really seeing White's
attack yet although if Magnus plays H4
and then sneaks that g Pawn up The Bard
Danny you can't fall asleep either if
you're wesle on the king side yeah no
it's it's interesting because
objectively White's Pawn storm has more
potential than blacks but there you go
also White's pawns are easier to Target
than blacks so Queen A5 is is is super
important for that keeping white off
balance and saying hey look okay if you
go all in for the attack I may grab this
Pawn at some point note that it's not a
thing you really do right now but uh if
you know one example is if you take with
the queen I think that white can just
can just trade and win material back but
but okay Rook E8 instead which is the uh
the move you were calling for top engine
move Rook AE and now H4 is very likely
and he does it and I think Magnus I
think we will see that in game Queen
takes D5 I wouldn't be able to resist
that juicy morsel I think Magnus will
trade and then push G5 and essentially
play for positional compensation in the
end game in the form of a space
advantage and maybe he'll win one of the
d uh the D pawns back likely the D4 Pawn
draw likeliest result but given what
we've seen in the end games thus far I'm
very much cautious about making a guess
uh and trying to forecast how what this
end game is going to look like 10 moves
from now but you're right Wesley takes
the pawn when it was more appropriate
that when I was highlighting that you
wouldn't take it earlier this Rook was
not on E8 and B4 would have been a move
and so the whole point is now Wesley has
taken the pawn at the right time and you
know
A3 such a Magnus Mo you know what he's
thinking about I I swear Magnus is
already trying to set a long-term trap
where this Rook runs out of squares
you're totally right B4 and F4 it's czy
to think about that Magnus Magnus is
Devious right now he wants to set a
long-term opportunity for his opponent
to blunder you and I've said that a lot
he does that better than anyone in
history right create chances for his
opponent to go wrong and let's just see
what happens and A3 is one of those
moves that you can easily look past but
if he wins the game it's going to be one
of the reasons that he did because he
forces Wesley to make a difficult
decision guess what if the pawn was on
B4 right now he would already be
threatening to trap The Rook with Bishop
C4 so these things that we're mentioning
they're not some farfetched you know
distant possibility they're the reality
that Wesley is facing and I would go
Rook C5 and Evacuate The Rook he's
missed it B4 I guess Wesley wants B5 but
can white go Bishop F1 and Bishop G2
there oh my gosh no but the move B4 it's
exactly what we said he was going for B4
literally traps The Rook right now and
whether it's Bishop C4 next or a slow
jam right throw the LI Richie and let's
uh let's enjoy ourselves with some
candles this a slow jam it doesn't
matter Magnus is trapping the rook and
and we knew it was going to happen when
he played A3 there's also Rook to E1
here to prepare Bishop B4 but Wesley is
relying on the Move Rook
E3 in response but white could still
play Bishop B4 and Danny this is such an
instructive point for newer players
right the X-ray defense Rook H E1 Rook
E3 and Bishop B4 you called it the
moment Magnus played A3 and now Wesley
is staring down the barrel uh of a
position where he's going to be down in
exchange I wish I could play half as
good as Magnus as as well as I predict
magnus's ideas because as soon as he
played A3 I asked myself what would
Magnus do and you you started to see the
purpose of it Wesley unfortunately lost
his focus by the way your move Rook e
one is more accurate than that Bishop F1
computer agreed and here comes Bishop B4
X or okay G5 accuracy oh my gosh he
stops H4 First kicks the bishop Bishop
E4 is next and Magnus Carlson is
trapping The Rook in the middle of the
board unbelievable how another game that
just makes your jaw drop open and G5
another one of those imperceptible
moments where Magnus prevented Bishop
takes H4 Danny how many players if we
could briefly pull up an analysis board
instead of G5 how many players would go
Bishop E4 and blunder Bishop takes H4
Rook takes C3 D takes C3 and guess what
black pre moves E2 and if you take on D5
with the Rook you actually lose the game
God so that's why he played
G5 what a crazy line you just saw there
and so Not only was G5 necess or most
accurate to save the H Pawn but I didn't
realize how deep the idea was I'm
showing da nitzki an instant replay cuz
sometimes you got to appreciate that's
amazing line da and and again a lot of
players guilty right here Yours Truly
probably would have just totally missed
that idea and you know that is crazy
it's he's an artist right and that this
is what artists do